[Applause]
okay I'm dressed you know y'all we're
all dancers - I found this out about you
know I'm not not like them I don't
swaying around yeah yeah yeah me my
sister my sister went to Kirov she was a
real dancer I was a fake dancer but I
pretend I think all dancers are dancers
I like tulle and tight yeah all right
your phone I know cuz I talked to my
cells all the time cuz you've dressed me
several times so I know that your phone
blows up at every award season do you
ever have to say no cuz the time or any
reason yeah yeah it's time that's all it
is it's like those moments where it's
like the night before and they're like I
need a custom dress for this tomorrow
and then you were like I like I want it
hot were like okay I mean every now and
then I'll do it
I will I think we did a dress for Ariana
in four hours and and it was amazing and
you were to dress that body yes yeah you
know like he is so beautiful yeah yeah
it just depends you know Wow all right
that's I was you're always so busy and I
get I'm always seeing everybody on the
carpet and I'm like almond Syriana
they're like me too like okay I'm I felt
you make me feel cool cuz I am never
that girl outside of that dimension
because of you and my stylist yes
[Applause]
your merrill dress you made the dress
for me that I met meryl streep yeah and
I like this because this is a little
different it's still your kind of cool
edgy rock moment but a little more
glamorous Golden Globe it was my first
time ever to go to anything like that
yeah always thinks like I go to music
things is so out of place it was amazed
that you were so good that night Meryl
not like Julia Roberts and they're like
really expensive clothing store her when
she you know pre I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my YouTube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this